so while you were growing up um as a
performer somewhere along the line you
got exposed to dungeons and dragons
so so i wanted to ask like uh when that
happened because i have to say deborah
um i played dungeons dragons as a kid
and uh
and um let's just say that you would
have stood out in our group
probably not many girls uh played yeah
yeah there were no girls
like our little uh group well that's
been some of the
some of the fun and some of the what
i've been sort of
feel sort of tasked to do with dungeons
and dragons now is i think
i didn't come to it till my mid-20s and
i think some of that was that i did feel
that there was a barrier to entry
that somehow it was like a secret club
and you had to be invited to come and
play and even if that wasn't necessarily
entirely true that was how it felt
as an outsider so i didn't come to it
till an adult and i think
now how much it's enriched my life and
how much i could have really used it
when i was a kid
um so my goal right now is to really
open it up
and say and it's been a it's been
something that wizards the two published
d d have been doing as well with this
recent edition
is say everyone come and play even if
you don't know the rules
even if you make mistakes this is just
about collaborative storytelling and
um you know learning how to be
spontaneous
um so i i keep in whenever i play i keep
inviting new players to come and play
with me that's my favorite thing to do
well i definitely wanted to dig into
this because this is like the i mean
it's like the greatest thing i've ever
i've ever heard or experienced oh my god
um because so i'm going to relate my
experience which is probably a little
bit more
customary uh so i'm a bit older than you
um i you know and i grew up in the 80s
uh and dungeon dragons was one of like
it's like the heyday
honestly like that you know 80s of those
dragons than the dice what addition did
you start playing
legitimately i think it was like the
original like there wasn't even an
ambition number
so there was basic dungeons dragons and
there was advanced dungeons and dragons
and they had like different
you know rules um and then it was second
edition advanced studies and dragons
would try to clean some of the stuff up
um but but but we were we were playing
like the og
keep on the borderlands like uh um
uh basic set do you have your books
still
um i think they might have literally
disintegrated from all of our
handling of them deborah because we had
our grubby paws
like childish paws and like endless
meals people that's good it should be
well used
these uh volumes um so it was
me my older brother and i'm telling you
the story this might entertain you
um so my brother is now a professor of
psychology
at nyu uh he got married like you know a
number of years ago
but my best man speech for him was about
how he was the dungeon master when we
were playing dungeon dragons like i was
trying to like paint a picture of us
growing up
so so it was him me and then our
neighbor
um and then there were there might have
been like some people that kind of came
in and out but really like the three of
us were like the core
because uh you know like we lived on the
same street
um and it was such like a way of
um when you you called it collaborative
storytelling but it was almost like a
way for
you to have this robust uh fantasy life
for yourself as a kid
and i was a very geeky asian kid my
brother was equally geeky
and so then you had these incredible
narratives about yourself as like this
dragon slaying hero going out in the
woods and taking all these risks and
like you know
like having all these achievements so it
was very
very important to um my sense of
happiness and belonging uh as a kid
um and you discovering it in your 20s as
a creative
and then have enjoying some of those
same elements like makes me really
happy um because in my case i associate
it with that idyllic time of life
um and the the thought of people
discovering it
um at later points um is just
like it's just an amazing idea to me oh
cool well i mean i think as an actor
so much of it is is about keeping that
inner
child that likes to play and have a rich
imagination alive and that's my job is
collaborative storytelling so this was
just a it's a lovely way to practice
it's a lovely way to
um feel a little bit more ownership over
a story as well because as an actor i'm
rarely writing or creating the story i'm
just sort of kind of trying to
live in it and absorb it so in dmd it is
that really nice sense of like oh this
originated from me in some regard and
yeah i saw that you were actually
writing the story lines and everything
else which is awesome i've really loved
uh game master you know being a game
master and um
write you know writing the stories and
leading a team through it's so much
responsibility
it can be yes you have to know all the
rules to some extent and
uh sometimes you know sort of solve some
social
things that go on at a table but i've
had
almost entirely positive experiences so
was there an individual that was kind of
your
introducer uh to this absolutely so
um my managers at the time
one of their sort of junior associates
he had been playing his whole life like
probably started
with the original you know went for
weekends but they would play for 30
hours straight
kind of thing and i had always said i
was so interested and i wanted to play
but i just didn't know how to get
started and he offered
to run a game for me and my friends so
he first introduced us
we played with him for about a year and
then
for our next campaign he sort of
suggested that we start to
switch the responsibility of writing
this the campaign
so i was the first one to go and i think
that's when it really bit me
and i said wow i can draw from my own
interests in these worlds and these
genres that i think are really
interesting
because i'm oddly not a big fantasy
person that was never
a huge part of my background i'm
more sort of children's lit that kind of
sort of
imaginative space rather than like dark
tolken
sort of fantasy so i lean a little more
that way a little more towards innocence
um so for me to be able to say wow this
is just a structure
that i can paint anything on it and
use it um so i can do something that
feels
you know like a storybook and not
necessarily tolkien asks if it sort of
leans more towards me so that has been
the fun of the last few years is sort of
putting my own stamp on it no deborah
i i ran for president you probably knew
that
so but but but there was this element um
that i had from dungeons and dragons
um so i i went to law school i my
parents who also like yours were very
into education
um so i went to law school and practiced
law unhappily for five months
and then left to start an ill-fated.com
um but but one of the the things that
drove me
um was i i had this quote from myself i
guess i don't know if you're allowed to
quote yourself but it was like that when
i was a kid growing up playing dinosaur
dragons
i didn't dream about being the scribe
like like i dreamt about going into the
woods and
slaying the dragon with the comparison
being that my lawyer job felt like
being described like where
i was just like you know like like and
the version of law i was practicing
which was corporate
transactions genuinely did feel like i
was documenting someone else's
accomplishments
like i really didn't feel like that and
so then i was like i should try and
accomplish something myself
yeah well there is something amazing
with d and d that it's about practicing
being heroic even an imaginative place
yes that's where rescuing innocent
people and
stopping the tyrants you know like that
is a beautiful thing to practice as a
kid and an adult
yeah so as a kid i practiced it all the
time and then i found
adulthood to be driving me in a very
different direction and i was
like and i think one of the sources of
strength i had to
try to start a business or do some of
the things i've done entrepreneurially
was from douglas the dragons was because
like you
had this sense that you could
paint your own picture of the future uh
and then try to actualize it
uh and i feel like artists and creatives
do that
entrepreneurs do that um in you know in
like
positive cases i mean you know um
politicians sometimes every once in a
blue
moon but
i'm so glad that you saw in those
dragons like this canvas that you could
paint and then you said you know what
like you know
like my version of it is going to be
like uh you know more
distinct to me well there's that and i i
think also it's a it's a wonderful
space to if again if you do it
right and safely with the right group of
people to explore identity as well
yes we don't have to be because the
characters you draw
up for yourself are just versions of
yourself
the versions of yourself that you aspire
to be or you're afraid to be or
even if you play a villain it might be
all the things that you're
scared about within yourself you know
and so it is this sort of space in which
to try on
hopefully safely and respectfully of
everyone else at your table
but to try on different aspects of who
you are and see how it feels and
and see how other people respond to you
and what that means and
i again i i think role-playing games
collaborative games are
such rich ground for that kind of
exploration
um again there are toxic tables and
things like that but
again the most part with your close
friends i just think it's a really
cool safe space especially for kids who
are still figuring out who they are
or who they want to be to experiment
with that thank you for
listening in i hope you enjoyed this
conversation if you did
please do subscribe to yang speaks and
click on notifications so we can let you
know
every time we have a new episode
bye